Hi, class. Dr. Jim here. We're finally to the last chapter, chapter 25, in which we're
going to look at the RNA viruses. And at the very end, talk a little bit about prions
again and just bring those back up. But the last chapter, chapter 24, we discussed the
DNA viruses and looked at a number of different viruses in that category. Today, what we're
going to be studying is looking at the RNA viruses. And again, that's the main way of
separation of the viruses, the DNA, versus the RNA. Structurally, they're very similar.
Again, some have the envelope, the membrane around it. Some just have the capsid, which
is the protein, okay, or all of them have the capsid, but again, some only have just
the capsid and not the envelope. And again, the RNA is divided, the families are divided
on how the RNA looks. Most of them are single-stranded. Some of them are going to be segmented single-stranded
RNA. Some of them are just one piece of RNA, and some are even double-stranded RNA. And
that's in the rheoviruses. Not a lot, but there are a couple that we will discuss today.
In this chapter, we're going to be looking at things such as influenza. We're going to
spend some time looking at HIV. And some of the other ones that you've probably been
vaccinated for like measles, mumps, rubella, those are all different types of RNA viruses.
We'll talk about the common cold, which is the rhino viruses. And then again, spend a
little bit of time talking about prions and what they do. And those are different than
viruses in looking at infectious protein particles. And so we'll look at that as well.
So let's begin. We got a lot to discuss today. Get it over with. This will be the last chapter.
And then we're done. So let's take a look. So again, we're going to be studying what
are the RNA viruses of medical importance. And again, most of the viruses we're going
to be looking at today are going to be the single-stranded variety. And again, we separate
them based on if they're enveloped, non-enveloped, segmented, non-segmented kind of different
things and look at these different types of things. The first one that we're going to
look at is influenza. And that is an envelope segmented virus, meaning that the RNA is found
in segments, different segments of division. The second group we're going to look at is
the envelope, non-segmented RNA viruses. And again, now this case is one long strand
of RNA with multiple genes on it. And it still has an envelope on the outside. And this includes
things like measles, mumps, rubella. I think we also talk about RSV a little bit in here
and a couple other diseases that we'll discuss. And then we'll get into the Abro viruses. The
Abro viruses are ones that are transmitted by mosquitoes. And that includes things like
West Nile. I don't have Zika virus in here, but that would be included in those yellow
fevers, another one, some of the hemorrhagic ones, like then gave fever and things like
that. So those are some of the Abro viruses that we were, or arboroviruses that we worry
about. The next group are going to be the retroviruses. And the retroviruses are a separate
family. And this includes HIV. So we're going to spend a little bit of time discussing HIV
looking at the epidemiology, the effects, and some of the treatments for that. And then
we'll spend a little bit of time looking at the non-enveloped viruses, RNA viruses, including
the polio, hepatitis A, and the rhinoviruses, which are the common colds. And then finally,
the very last virus, RNA virus we'll look at is the double-stranded RNA. And that includes
the rheovirus and the rhodoviruses. And those are typically seen in viral diarrhea and that.
So again, big problems, especially in other countries. Sometimes you hear about these
viruses infecting cruise ships and then everyone on the cruise ship. You hear about these massive
cases of diarrhea and that stuff. This is what we talk about these rhoda and rheoviruses
that spread very easily through hand-to-hand contact or very easily from one person to another.
The finally, to finish up today, we're going to be looking at are some of the infectious
protein particles. We've already talked a little bit about that in the virus chapter
and that's the pre-ons. I'll discuss a little bit more of how these things happen, how it
occurs in nature and what happens when the protein gets inside of you and what changes
and what causes this infection to occur. So we'll look at that as well. Okay, so we've
got a lot on our plate today. So let's start with the influenza virus.
All right, so again, the RNA viruses are a very diverse group of microbes and they're
a sign of 1 to 12 families based on the envelope, the capsid, and the nature of the RNA. And
we've already discussed some of those. Again, we're not going to cover all the RNA viruses,
but there are some that I think are more important than others, again, based on infection rates
and again, what you guys need to see, especially those going on to into medicine and looking
at this with nurses and that stuff. And then, again, you're going to see that there's a
lot more RNA viruses than DNA. DNA was primarily herpes. We talked about hepatitis B and we
also looked at some of these other ones like the warts, the human papillomavirus.
RNA viruses, more diverse, many more families, quite a few on there now. In my class, I don't
want to expect them to know the difference between a negative sense and a positive sense.
It all associates, do you have to make a copy of the RNA first? And can it be transcribed
right away or translated right away? So that's the difference between a positive and negative
and that. And I don't really get into that. Some of you that are taking this at another
place or listening to me and taking another place, your instructor might expect you know
the difference between a positive and negative strand. And again, a lot of that has to do
with which one is red. So sense means which RNA is red, which one isn't red, positive
is red, minus is not red and you have to go through a procedure to synthesize a new RNA
to get to a positive strand. But again, that's the extent that I would ask anything on my
type of test. This down here just shows you the typical way of going through the infection.
Again, the virus has to get in so it uses the spikes to get into the cell. Once it gets
into the cell, you have the encoding where the RNA is released and depending if you're
positive or negative, that's where you either have to make a new strand or non new strand.
RNA typically stays outside in the cytoplasm because it's already RNA and you have the
ribosomes already there. So there's no need to go into the DNA. The only time that you
do see it going into the nucleus again is if it's a positive negative strand. So if you're
a positive sense, you are ready to go. If you're negative, you can just stay, you can
stay in the nucleus. And so it kind of goes through and looking in there and figuring
out and then again, building the proteins, the proteins get made. It takes off the cells
and finally leaves the cells. So that's how the whole process goes. So let's take a look
first at the influenza. These are called the ortho manixoviruses. So a big name for what
we call influenza. And this is different than most of the other RNA viruses because it has
segmented RNA, has an envelope on the outside and has a number of unique features to it.
But the primarily what we're going to be talking about is influenza A type. Okay? And
so we'll look at that. So again, there are three distinct influenza virus types, A, B,
and C. And type A is the one that causes mostly infections. Here in this chart, you can see
a list of the different types of strains or subtypes that we worry about. And you see
the wonderful H and N. And H and N, stand, and we're going to talk about this is hemoglobin
and neuroramidase. And those are the spikes that are on the virus. And again, those signal
what type of strain or subtype it is. And so probably the last main one that a lot of
people remember is H1N1. And that was the one the swine flu just recently in the last,
I believe three or four years now. And so that was the last major pandemic that we had
of a flu strain. And so again, the H1N1 stands for the type of hemoglobin and neuroramidase
that's on there. And I'll talk about that here in a minute. But that's how we describe
these different strains. And you can see here, here the spikes and it has two different spikes
that interact with the cell receptors on the cell. Okay, again, how does the infection
occur? The virus attaches to and multiplies in the cells of the respiratory track. And
again, the segments of RNA enter into the nucleus and the finished viruses are assembled
and bought off the cell. And it's basically the picture I just showed you not too long
ago, how it comes in basically makes the new RNA and then leaves the cell. And while
once you leave the cell, you now can go and infect more cells. And so typically the infection
stays respiratory, not only the upper respiratory, but the lower respiratory can be affected.
And what it does is it damages your normal cilia movement and that cilia movement makes
it tougher to get things out. So a lot of times what you see with the flu are secondary
infections that are caused by some of the bacteria that we harbor in our throats. And
so that's the problem with flu. Flu itself doesn't necessarily kill people, even though
you feel awful during it. It's a lot of times the secondary pneumonia that develops along
with the flu that really knocks people out. And so that's what we're going to be talking
a little bit about here in just a minute. Okay, so again, the two glycoproteins that
are on the outside envelope of the flu virus or include hemaglutin, which is the H. And
again, they're 15 different subtypes. And then the neuroramidase is the N and there's
N and so what we always describe flu as as a combination of the H and N. And so you can
have an H1 and 15 or N9 type of thing in any of those combinations. And that shows you
how many different types of flu there really are out there and why you have to get vaccinated
every year because these things can change very easily. Okay, both glycoproteins frequently
undergo genetic changes, decreasing the effectiveness of immune response. And so one of the things
that makes flu really tough to vaccinate and look out for is that it changes very quickly.
It is a fast mutation has a very fast mutation rate can change very quickly. And so when a
person gets infected with one flu, it may mutate inside of them and when they pass the
flu on to someone else, it may be a completely different subtype in that in that sense. And
that's kind of the scary thing about flu and why sometimes the vaccine works really,
really well because typically it works well and it kills all the flu or you know, it prevents
you from getting the flu. Other times it works very poorly. Now back in 2015, the flu vaccine
did not work very well. I think it was only effective in about 23% of the population and
that's because they have to kind of figure out what are going to be the strains are going
to be effective. Well, that's six months in advance. Flu can go through a number of changes
and then by the time that the flu hits the United States and they figure out, oh, we've
been vaccinating these people with this these strains, it could be a completely different
strain and that the flu vaccine ends up being ineffective. Sometimes like this year with
2015, 2016, the flu vaccine worked really, really well and they actually got got the right
combinations. And so you didn't see a lot of talk about flu this year in the United States.
Now, in other countries, I'm not sure what the numbers were or anything else like that.
But in the United States, the flu rates were down quite a bit this year and that was due
to the high success rate or the high protection rate of the vaccine. And again, because flu
changes so quickly and new takes so quickly, it doesn't give your body enough to keep going
and using the same flu vaccine. That's why every year you have to get a new vaccine because
it does change so much. And so that's one of the problems with flu. So, and again, sometimes
it's a guessing game and how well it's going to work. All right. Now, again, I talked about
mutation and again, flu has a very fast mutation and we've talked about this constant mutation
as known as antigenic drift, meaning that it changes very quickly that the antigens that
are on the outside of the flu, the receptors, the HNN can change very, very quickly and mutate
and change and then it can go on to another person and be a completely different subtype.
That change or gradual change in the flu is called antigenic drift. Okay. So the change
over time. The antigenic shift is when now you have two or more flu viruses that mix
together into one. And the example of this is the H1N1. Now, the H1N1 was a unique type
of strain because what happened was, is that originally was in pigs. It was a swine flu
that was then passed in humans. And so, flu can go from one organism to another and change
and sometimes they mix together. So human flu strains can mix together with bird flu
or, or pig flu or some of these other flu varieties out there and now really makes a
dangerous combination. And when that happens, we call that an antigenic shift. And so again,
it can change very quickly. It takes RNA from another strain strand of flu and so it really
can cause serious problems. And that's why we're so worried about bird flu. When you
hear about all they had to kill millions of chickens like they did last year and here
in Wisconsin and other parts of the Midwest. It's because a lot of the birds got this bird
flu. And what they're worried about was that this would jump to people. And if it jumped
to people, this could be really scary. It could wipe out a lot of people very quickly. And
that because one, we don't have the protection that we do with the human flu, a lot of people
would get really, really sick and probably die from it. And so that's the scary thing.
And that's why we have to watch out for those things when they do our found in other animals
and hear about these different strains that it can jump to other other things and jump
into humans. And that's the scary thing. Now one that's going around right now, I know
in the Chicago area is the dog flu. And you might be hearing a little bit about that where
a lot of these dogs are getting sick with the flu and that stuff. Now this one tends
not to jump to humans. So we don't worry so much about that. But obviously it can be
a very serious consequence to dogs. And so if your dog does experience any flu-like symptoms
and again, it's a lot like what humans see, you know, you get the coughing, the sneezing,
high temperature, those things associated with it and you want to take your dog into
the vet very quickly because this could turn out to be very serious. And so there is a
vaccine for dogs as well out there. So if you are worried, I'll talk to your vet and
you may be vaccinated, especially if you take your dogs to dog parks and other places where
you get a mixing of dogs together, flu moves very easily through people, through contact,
same thing with dogs. So again, just something to just be aware of. Okay. So that's a lot
about the flu and the difference between antigenic drift and the shift. The shift is
to be basically when you mix two different, totally different viruses together and create
a new strand of virus. All right. So obviously influenza A, this is the one we're going to
be talking about most. It's acute, highly contagious respiratory illness. And as soon
as one person gets it, it seems to spread to about five other people right away spreads
very easily through water droplets in the air. It has seasonal pandemics. Again, very
easily, you can see the numbers go up in the winter time and then go down. And the reason
for that is obviously people are closer together in the winter. And that's why you see these
more often when people are closer together in close quarters, breathing in the same air.
Okay. It is a top 10 killer in the United States. And again, it's typically seen in
the elderly and small children. And that's again, the immune effects. And I would say
that along with the flu, it is the respiratory problems, the bacterial pneumonia that developed
that is the secondary consequence. And the secondary infection that leads to most of
the deaths is not flu itself, but other things that lead to it in the pneumonia and other
things that can develop. What it does is advise the affiliated cells of the respiratory mucosa
causes a rapid shedding of cells stripping the silio away from the respiratory. And so
again, you get severe inflammation of the respiratory system, making it tougher to breathe. Feeling
like you're constricting right away. And again, allows for these other things that are already
living in us to go down and cause infection, because now our immune systems are weakened.
Part of the difference between colds and flu is, and we're going to look at this later
on when we talk about colds, is that you get a high fever with flu, headache, Malaysia,
which is just an overall tiredness, fear and geo pain, shortness of breath and coughing
and all associated. And really, you know, when you have the flu, it's different than
a cold because you just feel like you're at death's end, that you're just kind of wiped
out. And you just, you heard all over. It's just not one of those things. A cold is typically
up in your head. A lot of times, you know, the sneezing, the coughing and that not a lot
of fever associated with flu is just the whole body aches, fever, you know, coughing, sneezing,
sometimes associated with this, tightness in the chest, maybe a secondary pneumonia develops
types of those. And again, we can host defenses, then sets patients up for the secondary infections,
especially pneumonia. So a lot of times you see someone really gets hit by the flu, they'll
develop a secondary infection. This is why in children and elderly patients, this can
be very deadly in that, if it's sped, especially if it gets into like a nursing home situation,
where you have lots of close contact, people are already sick with other things. And now
that thing can spread and really take a bite out of the nursing home population. So that's,
that's a scary thing to think about when flu comes around. Okay, diagnosis treatment and
prevention. Again, there are some rapid immunofluorescence tests to detect the antigens and the type
of virus that you have. To control it, there are some antiviral drugs out there, including
Relenza and Tamiflu. However, the, the period of when you can take those is short. So you
have to know you got infected with the flu and you have to just start feeling the symptoms.
When you first start feeling the symptoms, that's when you have to take it. It does
you know good if you take it out. Let's say you'd say your neighbor has the flu and you
just say, I'm going to take some Tamiflu so I don't get it. I'm not going to help you
anymore. And then the other thing is, is that once you get it and maybe you got severe,
you know, severe symptoms, again, it's really not going to do any good. It might lessen
the symptoms maybe for a day or two, but it really doesn't do you much good once you
have a full blown infection going on at that time. Again, flu virus has developed a high
rate of resistance to some of these different drugs, including the endomatidine and the
endomatidine and that stuff. So again, sometimes those aren't effective. And again, typically
what you see is an annual trivalent vaccine. And if you're going into the medical field,
a lot of times the hospitals and the doctors you work for will require you to take it.
So it's part of your job description that you have to take it. Now, why is it a trivalent?
A lot of times what they do is they throw in at least three different subtypes of virus
in there because again of the mutation, the antigenic drift that goes on. And so a lot
of times they won't just speculate and say one, one virus, but say three viruses. Sometimes
it can be up to five in those things and depending on it. And I know the last couple of years
they've also included the H1N1 as just a precaution because that has gone around and spread to
a lot of people. And so that that one is there. I will say that I highly recommend doing this.
I myself, even though I'm not in the medical field, I do teach classes, but I know a lot
of you guys coming into my classes do have little kids. They get the flu. You guys could
spread it and I can't be out for weeks and weeks and weeks obviously. So I try and keep
myself healthy and that and I do get the vaccine. I think it's perfectly safe. There are some
people that do suffer from some immune or flu-like symptoms. And again, that is because your immune
system is recognizing the virus and then going through the process of that primary response.
And sometimes that primary response will give you some symptoms that feel like you have
the flu and that's part of the natural cause. Most of the time though, most people have
just soreness in the arm, maybe in the armpit because of the flu draining into the lymph
nodes and that. But otherwise, it's only a couple days and then you get over it. One
nice thing, even if it isn't as effective like it was last year, it does help lessen
the symptoms. And so you might still get the flu, but your overall health and that stuff
might be better improved and the symptoms might not be as bad because you did have the
vaccine because your body can kind of respond to it already very early. And so again, typically
what you can do when you get the flu is ease the flu symptoms. And again, the good hygiene
and good practice and that stuff, that's the best way to avoid a wash in your hands, especially
when you come in contact with things and that stuff. But that's the biggest thing is, again,
remember, flu can be spread everywhere and just keeping yourself healthy, that's the
biggest thing. Okay, so again, which of these happen in case of the antigenic shift of influenza
A? Single mutations in the hemoglutinin, recombination of RNA segments between bird
and human strains, a change from influenza A to B, or both and B. What happens when we
talk about antigenic shift? Okay, now the shift remember is when two strains come together.
And so the idea is the recombination of RNA segments between bird and human strains. And
so that's the one we really worry about is when you get a whole new strain, when you
get a combination of two, that's why we worry about the bird flu and things like this is
those things can come together and form a new deadly strain of human flu. So the single
mutations in the hemoglutinin is a drift, okay, that's that slow change over a period
of time, whereas the recombination of two strains, that's the shift. Okay, good job if you got
it right. All right, so let's move on to the envelope non segment, single stranded RNA
viruses, and there's quite a few in this group. A lot of them that you probably have heard
of is measles, rubella, you may have heard about rabies, obviously, and then hepatitis
C. But there's a number of different ones that are out there. These are the names of
the viruses or the family of viruses and include the paramexoviruses, the rabbit oviruses, the
corona viruses, the toga viruses, and the flaviviruses. And so all these different viruses
out there can cause disease. Again, we talk about these different things. Hepatitis C
is very scary because it can lead to, again, severe liver problems and then we talked about
hepatitis B already, but C is even worse than the B in that case in causing symptoms and
that measles, mumps, and rubella, which are part of the MMR vaccine. If you have it, you're
protected. But again, we've seen increases of these things going, especially in those
that haven't been vaccinated. Rabies is associated with wild animals. We'll talk a little bit
about that. And SARS is one of those that came out about 15 years ago. We haven't heard
much since. There have been a few outbreaks here and there, but it hasn't been one that
has been this major outbreak or pandemic. We were really worried back in 2002, 2003, when
the spread through a lot of different countries, but it really died off quickly once we isolated
people. And we didn't really see much. But again, we'll talk about all these things.
Now, all of them have an envelope and they all have a single stranded RNA on the inside.
That's non-segmented. Okay. So again, the paramix of viruses includes the mumps, the
measles, and the RSV or respiratory syncytia virus, which can be pretty nasty, especially
to very, very young kids. These are all spread through respiratory transmission. They have
an envelope, has a glycoprotein, and F spikes that initiate cell-to-cell fusion. So you
end up getting these, what are called these giant cells. And then the easiest, easiest
is spread from one cell to another because these giant cells form with these viruses.
And so again, fusion with the neighboring cells caused the multinucleate giant cells
to form. And that's one of the signs to look for when you see these types of infections
going on. Now, mumps will be the first one that we talk about. Again, humans are the only
reservoir, and about 40% of the infections are subclinical and lead to a lifelong immunity
or long-term immunity. There's roughly 300 cases in the United States, but most of us
are vaccinated. And if you're vaccinated for it, you are protected. Most of the time we
hear this is someone that hasn't been vaccinated, or they weren't vaccinated correctly. And
so that leads them to the process of getting this infection. Incubation Committee, we're
from two to three weeks. It includes fever, muscle pain, malaise, classic swelling, or
one of both cheeks. And so that's the clear sign of mumps, is that you get the swelling
of the prada glands in the cheeks. And so that causes that swelling to occur. It's those
glands in the celebratory glands and that stuff in there. And so that's what you see
in those cases. And that's why mumps is very distinctive. Again, it's usually uncomplicated
invasion of other organs. In 23rd or 30% of infected adult males, the epidemic's intestines
can be infected and it can cause swelling. It could lead to sterility, but that is in
a rare case. And again, symptomatic treatment, meaning that again, treating of the symptoms,
and then there is the live attenuated vaccine. And so again, associated with mumps is the
painful swelling of the prada salivary glands. Okay, so you get the swelling of the cheeks,
kind of the chipmunk cheeks, associated with the mumps. Okay, measles is another one. And
this is the morbidia virus. And it's also known as the red measles rubola. It's different
than the rubella. So we're going to look at that in a minute with the German measles.
It's very contagious and it's transmitted by respiratory aerosols. Humans are the only
reservoir in there, typically only less than 100 cases a year in the United States. However,
people wide outside the United States where vaccinations haven't taken place, you see
a lot more deaths associated with this. Down here is the two forms and measles. You have
the rubola and the rubella. And again, these are the two different types. We're going
to be talking about these things and what can happen. Okay, the last major outbreak
that we had in the United States was 2015. And this was the cases that started in Disneyland.
So this is right around Christmas time last year. And what happened was is that a family
had a child that was sick. They went to Disneyland and that spread to other children who left
Disneyland and went across the country and it spread to form a number of cases throughout
the United States. Approximately had about 130 cases, which is abnormal. And again, the
real reason for this was because those kids that were infected were those that were non-immunized.
And so again, the ones that were immunized were perfectly safe. No one that was immunized
to it got sick. It was those that their families chose them not to be immunized or they couldn't
be immunized. Now, there is that situation where some children are just so sick to begin
with they can't be immunized or they have some other issues that they can't be immunized.
And that puts them at risk. So if we talk about that herd mentality and that protecting
those that can't be immunized, that's the reason why we want to immunize as many people
as possible to protect those that can't be immunized. And so that's where this problem
started is that it's spread through people that chose not to be immunized and that spread
it to ones that couldn't be immunized. And so that's the scary thing. And so again, we'll
look at the other types of measles here in just a moment, but this is just one of those
things. Here is the Robola. So you get the very typical spotted rash that's associated
with this and again, very contagious spreading throughout. Now, another thing that you see
with the, with the measles is that you get the sore throat, dry cough, and you get these
white spots or oral lesions called coplic spots and they're typically found the mouth,
the tongue, and the back of the throat. And so that's an identification of the measles
along with that red rash. And so you see that red spotted rash along with the coplic spots.
That's a sure cell, cell, sign that you have measles in that case. Those are the two things
I look for. And again, typically in people that haven't been vaccinated with the MMR
are the ones at risk for this disease. Okay. And again, there is a complication with measles
and it's the most serious complication. Again, in very few cases does this actually happen,
but the measles can go to the brain and it causes a progressive neurological degeneration
of the cerebral cortex. And I think this was a case that was on house. If you ever watched
that show house and the, you know, only had all these crazy theories and that stuff. And
I think one of the cases they talked about was the kid getting measles and actually caused
the subacute scourosing of the brain. And so essentially what happened is the virus was
eating away at the brain. Again, it's very, very rare in the cases of measles. It's in
one case in a million infections of measles and you consider the number of infections
per year is very, very small. And again, it involves a very defective virus that spreads
to the brain. And by cell fusion and it destroys the cells, it can lead to a coma and death
in anywhere from months to years. And again, vaccination is a way to prevent this. So if
you don't want your kids to get sick from these things, vaccinate. Okay. And I'd say,
you know, people worry about all these different things and that with vaccines, I would rather
have my child be vaccinated and protected from some of these diseases that they shouldn't
have to get rather than worrying about some of the side effects that they might get from
these things. And that's my personal opinion. Other people have their own. And you have
to make that decision for yourself. But I think there is a worthwhile idea of why we
vaccinate and what what the importance is for doing that. Okay. All right. Another one
is the RSV. And this is the respiratory syncytial virus or RSV. It's also known as the pneumovirus
and essentially this affects very young kids where we see it is that it affects the upper
respiratory track and produces these giant multi nucleate cells. It is a prevalent cause
of respiratory infection in children six months or younger. And it obviously the most susceptible
to this serious disease. And again, weak immune systems haven't been developed yet. Essentially,
they breathe these viruses in or through the eyes it replicates in the nasal pharynx, it
causes fever, rhinitis, pharyngitis, oitis, and crew. That's a sign of it. And that again,
a respiratory very small kids very tough to fight off again. There is a monoclonal antibody
that blocks attachment, but you have to get it early because again, the longer you wait,
the less effective it's going to be because you're more infection. And a lot of times
it's a hurry. And it's kind of like a, you know, very cautious period of time when the
child is fighting through this because they're very small, they have trouble breathing, you
know, and that with this. And so it can be very, very sleepless nights for parents that
have this virus. And it can be, it could lead to mortality if left untreated or again, if
it progresses to a very, very long state type of thing. And again, getting treatment for
that and knowing and getting the doctor's involvement is very important in these situations. Okay,
much worse than just a regular cold in these cases. Okay, another virus and we'll spend
a little bit of time is rabies. And this is the raptovirus and it's in the loss of virus.
And again, it's an interesting virus because it's different than a lot of the viruses that
you see. Most of the time we think of the Acosylhedral virus wrapped in an envelope.
Well, these guys are kind of the helical viruses and they're kind of a bullet shaped virus.
And so you can kind of see it here in the electron micrograph. And here's what it looks
like in the cartoon form. It's a slow progressive zoonotic disease and typically it's found
in wild animals. Okay, and wild mammals and that that are outside your house and that
stuff. We vaccinate our dogs and cats, especially if they go outside so that they don't get
bit by an animal, they don't get rabies and that stuff. We don't vaccinate humans and
that stuff. But again, it can be spread to both wild and domestic mammals through bites,
scratches and inhalation of droplets. Okay. Now, this shows you the populations that
actually carry the rabies in the different parts of the country, the United States. So
you can kind of see where you live and where rabies are. However, another one I would throw
up there is bats as well. Bats are considered a lot of times having rabies and that stuff
in Milwaukee last summer or the summer before there was actually a rabies warning out there.
So don't come in contact with bats because they did find a number of bats were infected
with rabies at the time. And a lot of times the rabies don't do a whole lot to these animals
that actually carry it. It's the ones that they spread it to. So if it spreads to another
animal, you get these infections or to a human where you can have dire consequences with
these infections. Okay. With the rabies, typically the virus enters through the bite, grows at
the trauma site for a week and then multiplies and then enters the nerve endings and advances
to the brain. So what happens is a wild or a rabid dog or wild animal will bite the person.
The virus gets in, multiplies at the site for a while. It's a long term type of infection.
Then it gets into the nerves and then it travels up the nerves through the spinal cord to the
brain. And so you get these different types of things. Then eventually what happens is
that when the virus has made it to the brain, it will then move to the salivary glands so
that you can then go bite other people or bite other animals and spread the disease.
Okay. And so that's the progression of the disease. Now there are clinical phases of
the rabies. It's called the pro-dormal phase where you have fever, nausea, vomiting, headache,
fatigue and some experienced pain, burning, tickling at the site of the wound. Okay. And
so that would be at about the first couple stages, you know, very early on when you get
bit with the thing. Then you have the furious phase. This is when the virus actually gets
into the brain, you get agitation, disorientation, seizures, twitching and hydrophobia. So you
get afraid of the water type of thing. And this is one of those things. Then you get
into the, what is called the dumb phase, which is where you get paralysis, disoriented and
stuporous where basically your brain is not functioning, you're leading into coma, which
then gets into the coma phase and then results into death. Again, early treatment is what
you want to do. So if you get bit by an animal and you don't know if that animal has been
vaccinated for rabies, you always have to bring either the animal in or just take the precautions
and go through the rabies procedure going through the shots and everything else. Because you
don't want to take a chance in that that animal having rabies and then letting it go and then
letting this progress to a further stage. The farther you wait, the less likely you are
going to survive from this disease. And so that's the scary thing with this. Okay. So
let's move on. And then again, after autopsies, so this is after you died. Okay. What they'll
do is they'll do an autopsy and look for these negative bodies that forms in the nervous
tissue. And you can see these are the negative bodies in the nervous tissue where basically
these things are voices filled in the brain. They're again, the bite from the wild or stray
animals, the demands assessment of the animal, animal meticulous wound care and specific
treatment. So again, if you get bit by an animal, they want the animal because they want
to test it for rabies. Unfortunately, they'll have to put the animal down if they have no
records of vaccination because they want to look to make sure that the animal itself doesn't
have rabies. And so they look at the brain and other things like that. So again, if the
dog hasn't been vaccinated for rabies that could put that potential dog down for that
reason alone. Okay. Again, preventative therapies initiated if signs of rabies do appear. And
again, treatment includes passive and active post exposure immunization. Again, it used
to be a number of different shots. I think they used to say 20 shots to the abdomen or
25 shots. Now it's down to I think about 12, but it's still quite a few shots. And so
it's not something that you really want to go, Hey, I want to go get rabies so I can
get all these shots. And so it's one of those things that can happen. You know, if you're
especially an outdoors person, you get bit by an animal or come in contact scratch by
an animal can happen. Now there is something what is called the Milwaukee protocol. And
so some of you may have heard of this. And some of you especially here in Wisconsin know
this, this, this girl who actually got bit by a bat about, I think it was now almost 10
years ago up in Fondilac, she was bit by a bat. She didn't realize that she had rabies
or the bat had rabies and that stuff. She went on her own way, dressed the wound. Everything
was fine. And then started developing the symptoms of rabies weeks after, after she
got bit. Well, by that time, it was too late to go through the normal protocol. So what
happens is essentially what the doctors did at Children's Hospital has done this special
technique where they put her in a medically induced coma, gave her antivirals and she miraculously
survived. Now she had to go through a long period of recovery. She had to relearn how
to walk, talk and a number of other things, but she did survive. They've tried this treatment
in a number of other patients. And unfortunately, it's only had about a success rate of five
out of 35. So it's not the best thing in the world. It's not going to save you all the
time from rabies, but it's better than not saying, well, you got no hope in this case.
So in this situation, it does work, but not at all. And we don't know why certain ones
do. And again, a lot of it has to do probably with age and, you know, how well your immune
system's working and everything else and how healthy you are as a person to begin with.
Okay. Again, control of rabies is through vaccination of domestic animals. So you bring
your dogs and cats in to get a rabies shot once a year or twice a year in order, once
or one or two or three years, you type the thing and again, elimination of strays and
strict quarantine practices. And again, there is a live oral vaccine incorporated and debate
for wild animals and that stuff. So that again, to control the spread of rabies through populations.
And again, over here shows you how it happens. You get the bite enters into the spinal cord
goes to the brain. And again, all these different animals can carry it and pass it on to humans.
And again, you see all these different things that can occur and that. And so that's these
are the things that can happen. Here's the hydrophobia. Again, the foaming at the mouth
after drinking water produces spasms in the throat and you start to foam and other things
like that. And so that's kind of that hydrophobia part that's associated with it. Now, an interesting
thing is you guys that are out there that like the walking dead and all these other things
may have heard some stories and some of these like I am legend and that stuff and how they
create zombies and rabies. And I like how to do this and that stuff. And so I just kind
of threw this in here because this is kind of what they always think about how these
zombies come about and that stuff and the zombie apocalypse is basically a form of rabies
that spreads the humans that become undead and basically affects the brain and they just
want to eat things. And so that's the idea. And so you think of these different types
of movies and that stuff. A lot of them are based on these types of things. And again,
you kind of look at the difference between rabies and zombies and you can see some similarities
where again, you get muscle spasm, convulsion, anxiety, restlessness, hyper-celevation and
zombies. They just want to eat and that stuff and you might be missing body parts and that
stuff obviously undead. I just throw that in some comic relief. But again, you might see
this a lot of times in movies and that's kind of what they think. You know, the zombie would
come kind of the rabies and you kind of become this stuporist walking around wanting to eat
brains and other things like that kind of biting people and that stuff. And that's the
idea with the rabies. The connection between rabies and zombies and that. So I think it's
kind of funny. All right. So for which of these diseases are active and passive immunization
given simultaneously? Is it influenza, yellow fever, measles or rabies? So which one do you
get both active and passive? So passive is the antibodies and that active is giving you
to make memory and that stuff. So which one of these do we talk about active and passive?
If you heard anything I talked about about the vaccination, it would be rabies. And rabies
again is the one where you get multiple shots. You get both active doses to stimulate the
immune system as well as some antibodies to block the toxicity of the rabies virus itself
and neutralize the rabies virus. Okay. So if you got rabies, you did a good job there.
Well, I don't want rabies, but you know what I mean. Okay. Another virus that's out there
that's enveloped is the coronavirus and this is a relatively large RNA virus with distinctively
spaced spikes on their envelopes. It's common in domesticated animals and there are three
types of human coronaviruses that have been characterized. There's an HCV, which causes
a cold. There's an intervirus that causes diarrhea and then the one that we worry most
about is this severe acute respiratory syndrome or SARS and this is an airborne transmission
and about 9% of those who get infected with it will die. And again, the major outbreak
was in China. It did spread to Canada. We did have a couple cases here in the United
States, but primarily through good isolation and keeping those people away and recognizing
the virus when it did happen, controlled the outbreak pretty quickly in those situations.
Now again, this was a newly emerging disease in 2002. It's transmitted through droplet
or direct contact. And again, the symptoms are fever, body aches and malaise may or may
not experience respiratory systems with breathing problems and the most severe cases can result
in respiratory distress and death. The diagnosis relies on the exclusion of other likely agents
like flu and other things like that. And again, there's not a vaccine for this. So it's more
of a supported treatment. And again, where we saw the major outbreaks was in China and
in Canada where the number of cases in the United States, we do have a few cases here
and also in Europe and Brazil, but again, not nearly as many as they did experience
in China and Canada. And again, that was due to travelers going from China over to Canada
and that stuff. And when you spread these things, it can be very quickly through the use of
airplane travel. And so that's where we see these kind of infection spreading.
Okay, another one is the rubella. And again, this is part of the MMR, the mumps, measles
and rubella. And again, measles, mumps and rubella and rubella is the virus that causes
the German measles. And again, it's in a sort of single strand RNA with a loose envelope.
It's endemic disease. There are places around the world that carry it. And again, most cases
are reported in adolescence and young adults and they're transmitted through contact with
respiratory secretions. And again, it's based on diagnosis based on serological testing.
There's no specific treatment available. However, vaccination is the key part. What can cause
or what causes here is again, you don't get that full overall body rash that you see with
the measles, the red measles in that case. This is the German measles and you get splotches
around the body. So that's one thing. It can lead to heart disease. It can lead to microencephalate
and cephalate in the brain, so shrinking of the brain. And it could lead to eye abnormalities
as well, including cataracts, glaucoma and some of these other things that can infect
vision as well. Again, early vaccination prevents you from ever having to worry about this disease.
There are places in the world that this is endemic. But again, use of vaccination really
helps prevent the spread of this disease. Okay. Again, there are two clinical forms. The post-natal
rubella includes malaise, fever, sore throat, and lendapathy. There is a rash, generally mild,
lasting about three days. And again, here is a more severe case, but typically you get more
of these splotches, not like the red measles words all over the body. In this case, it really
shows all over the body. And then there's the other one, which is the congenital rubella,
where the infection is during the first trimester when the baby is developing. And it's most likely
induced miscarriages or multiple defects in cardiac abnormalities, ocular lesions,
deafness, mental and physical retardation can occur. And so this poor baby got exposed
during the first, during the development. And so for you, though, for you guys out there that
haven't had a biology class or development class, human development, the first 12 weeks
are the most important part. This is where all the systems come together. This is where all the
systems are formed. And then the last two trimesters are where all the growth takes place. And so
really everything is developed within those first three months. And so if any infection occurs in
those three first three months, that can affect the development of those organs and other things.
And so that's where the problems can arise. And so obviously being vaccinated yourself will
prevent the spread to your unborn child. And so that's the key in those situations.
Okay, now another virus that's out there is the Flavavirus. This is the Hepatitis C or HCV. And
again, we talked about Hepatitis D already. And we'll talk about A in a little while. And these are
acquired through blood contact, blood transfusions, needle sharing by drug abusers and that. And so
again, fluid contact. Now again, with these infections, the varying characteristics 75 to 80 percent of
people that do get infected with HCV will remain infected indefinitely and can have possible severe
symptoms without permanent liver damage. Now again, some of the symptoms will occur. Will you get
jaundice? You get pain? And other things associated what we talked about before, sometimes fever,
malaise, other things. More commonly, you can have chronic liver disease or without overt
symptoms and that stuff. Sometimes you find yourself where you get cured of it all the way.
And this kind of just shows you the course of illness. And you get acute affection, about 60 percent.
I think that's 60. Maybe it's 80 percent. I think it's 80 percent. Actually, we go on to chronic
inflammation of liver. This is when you'd have the symptoms of jaundice and that. So 20 percent
will be cured from those things. And then the rest leads to fibrosis, you can get cancers, cirrhosis
and other issues with the liver. And again, treatment with Interferon and Revampin, less
than liver damage. There is no cure. However, there are a few drugs out there now that we're
finding that our potential cures for this disease are very, very expensive. But it seems that they're
now effective at curing disease. And hopefully over time, the amount of money it is for these
cures will go down and make it available for everyone. But for now, unless you have lots of money,
it's going to be very tough to survive or to get a cure from this disease. There is no vaccine for
HCV. So that's the difference between HBV and HCV is that there's no cure. And again, HCV,
even though you're less likely to show any symptoms, you're more likely to get liver, cancer, cirrhosis
and other things. So I would say HCV is one of those things where you're really going to,
that if you get it, you can have really direct consequences in the future with liver problems,
liver cancer, cirrhosis and some other things that go on in those situations. So HCV is not
something you want to mess around with. So again, if you're working with blood or blood products,
you want to be very, very careful handling those things and get tested. If you need to,
if you get a needle prick or something else, because it is one of those things that you have to worry
about in those situations. Now, the next group of viruses, again, there are a number of different
families, but the reason why I call these abroviruses is because they're spread by
arthropods. So it's the arthropod-borne viruses or abroviruses and the abroviruses are spread through
mosquitoes, ticks and other things. And we're going to primarily focus on the mosquitoes today
in that West Nile and some of the other ones, but there are other ones that do carry other
insects, insects and arachnids that do carry some of these viruses that are out there. So again,
just be aware of that. But today, we're going to focus primarily on the mosquitoes.
Now again, viruses sped by the arthropod vectors. This includes mosquitoes, ticks,
flies and gnats. There are about 400 viruses that are on there and they include the different
families of toga viruses, flaviviruses, some bonya viruses and rheoviruses. And again,
most illnesses are caused by these viruses are mild fevers. Some do cause severe encephalitis
and some can also lead to life-threatening hemorrhagic fever, which again, hemorrhagic
means you start to bleed from all the orifices and that and essentially that would be like Ebola
and some of these other ones that you really worry about the hemorrhagic fever that's associated.
Again, typically with these things are spread through a vector and the ones that we're going to be
talking about today are primarily mosquitoes. The one that I don't have on here because it's so
new is the Zika virus. So I don't have anything today about the Zika virus, but that is one that
is spread through mosquitoes. So again, this summer is going to be real interesting to see how far
those mosquitoes do travel up. They're now saying those mosquitoes could get into the United States
and travel up. So we might see more incidents of Zika virus, especially here in the United States
when summer comes and mosquitoes do come out. So that's going to be something really interesting
to keep an eye on. But again, I don't have anything on the Zika virus per se in this lecture today.
Okay, the influence of the vector, again, the vectors and viruses tend to be clustered in the
tropics and again, where do you have your mosquitoes and that stuff. Again, the abrovirus's life cycles
are closely tied to the ecology of the vectors. So again, in the northern hemisphere and again,
in Europe, we have seasons and that stuff. So again, with the seasons, you have more than mosquitoes
are prevalent and when they're not prevalent. And so you see the swings in those types of things.
And again, infections show peak incidents when the arthropod is actively feeding and reproducing.
Again, humans can serve as the dead end accidental host or can be a maintenance reservoir, depending
on how many people get infected. And then again, mosquitoes bite and spread the disease. And again,
controlling the vector controls the disease. Anytime you can eliminate the mosquitoes and flies and use
precaution, that's going to be the way to protect yourself. Now another one that's out there is
denieg denieg or denieg fever. And then this chikagunya, which is a virus that's spread through
mosquitoes. And again, if you're going to areas like Jamaica and the Caribbean, those are where
you see these types of diseases. And again, you can prevent it by preventing yourself from getting
mosquito bites. So making sure you wear long sleeves, bug spray and things, especially when
you're going into the jungle areas and that stuff, where you find high prevalence of mosquitoes.
Okay, now again, typically with the abroviruses, most of these are undifferentiated from a mild
fever or rash. There's no long term effects. Problem symptoms are fever, headache, melasia,
joint stiffness and rash. And so again, typically that would be in the more severe cases. You can
go into the environmental encephalitis where it does go to the brain and can cause a swelling of
the brain. And so the brain, meninges and spinal cord are involved and get convulsions, tremor,
paralysis, loss of coordination, memory deficits, changes in speech, personality, coma, survivors
may experience permanent brain damage associated. And here you can see someone with a scan where
you can see where the orange color is where you have the encephalitis where the brain is actually
swelling in those patients. And again, that's due to the virus getting into the bloodstream
and then traveling and crossing the blood brain barrier and affecting that.
Now, one that we do deal with in the United States that we do know every year that happens is the
West Nile virus. And luckily, most people have very few or asymptomatic comparing this disease.
Again, birds are the reservoirs. And so again, that's why they always look for dead birds
here and anywhere in the Midwest or really anywhere in the country. When they find dead birds,
they do test them for West Nile. And they say, oh, West Nile has been reported. It means that
it probably is in the mosquitoes. Now again, it's a newly emerging disease. And about 20% of us that
do get bit and get infected and actually show symptoms only 20%, 80% of us don't show any symptoms
whatsoever, not even a fever rash or anything. So probably a lot of us have been infected and
don't even know it. Now you can get a rash that develops along with the fever and that and encephalitis
and out of those 20% that do get show symptoms, only 1% of those actually show disease. So the
mild symptoms appearing in about in some people, about 20% include fever, headache, nausea, vomiting,
body aches and swollen lymph nodes. So if this is the summertime and you know, you got bit by
mosquitoes and you feel any of those things, you probably have a low grade case of West Nile. Now,
I'm not saying that you do if that's some of the symptoms, but that could be potential symptoms
that you have. Now, some serious symptoms now if you're in that 1% group or less than 1%,
you could have again, high fever, headache, neck stiffness, stupor disorientation, coma,
tremors, convulsions, muscle weakness, vision loss, numbness and paralysis. And again, that's
associated when you have the severe form of this disease. And again, typically you hear maybe one
or two cases out of the whole country that actually experienced it. And again, in the last couple
years, I think the number of West Nile virus cases is very limited, maybe 100 cases altogether.
And out of that, only a few have the severe cases. And a lot of times the 100 cases are the mild
symptoms. There are some other ones that are out there that can cause encephalitis and that,
and again, have very low numbers. And this includes the Colorado tick fever, western equine, encephalitis,
eastern equine, and California encephalitis. So all these things, again, can be spread by
mosquitoes and ticks and other animals. And so if you like to be outdoors in the summer,
always be aware that there's always the potential to get a disease from one of these
vectors getting bit. And most people just kind of, oh, I got a mosquito bite, no big deal,
but it could lead to severe complications if something develops. And again, it's rare,
but it could happen. And now with the Zika virus, it might be even scarier about that.
Okay. So some of these hemorrhagic fevers that are out there include yellow fever. Now this has
been eliminated in the United States. However, in other areas of the world, there are areas that
are endemic. And if you do plan to travel to those areas, they will vaccinate you for that.
And again, it's a short term vaccination in that. Again, there are two patterns of transmission.
There's the urban cycle, which is humans in mosquitoes. And then there's the Silvan cycle,
which is the forest monkeys in mosquitoes in South America. And again, associated with that is a
cute fever, headache, muscle pain, made progress to oral hemorrhage, nosebleed, vomiting, jaundice,
liver, and kidney damage. And it has a significant, significant mortality rate if you're not vaccinated
for it. So if you're going to some of these areas, and you don't get vaccinated for it,
you're taking a risk and potentially getting this disease. Now the other one is dengue fever,
which again is a flava virus and it's carried by the needy's mosquito. It's not in the US,
but it's usually a mild infection. But you can get dengue hemorrhagic shock syndrome,
and you can get break bone fever, extreme muscle and joint pain could be fatal if you do get in.
Here's some of these different phases that you see again. Severe could have some bleeding
associated with this, bloody vomiting, other things, nose and mouth bleeding, headache,
severe, severe cases. And again, and that stuff, and it just kind of shows you some of the things
that can occur with dengue fever. So again, you got to be very careful. And again,
typically we see dengue in Africa. Sometimes in South America, but typically it's more localized
to Central Africa and that in the areas, the tropical forest areas, but it's not in common
that a couple people do get this a couple times a year going to different places. And
you know, and getting this disease getting bit by mosquitoes. So just be aware of those hemorrhagic
fevers. Now it's similar to Ebola. Ebola is transmitted in a different way. That's through skin,
you know, fluid contact and everything else. It's not a vector through mosquitoes. So Ebola is
a completely different type of thing, but it does cause symptoms that are very similar to what you
see with the yellow fever and then dengue fever. Okay. All right. And so that's, this is some of
these abroviruses that are spread by arthropods or mosquitoes in particular. Now we're going
to spend a little bit of time talking about the retroviruses. Now retroviruses were found in the
80s. And so that's, you know, I always have that little joke. It's not named retrovirus because
it's from the 80s, but it's a retrovirus because it goes from RNA to DNA and that uses the reverse
transcriptase. And so that's where it gets the name retrovirus. And again, the most common one
we hear about is the human immunodeficiency virus or HIV. And so that's what we'll look at today.
All right. So HIV's and infections and AIDS. And again, it's a human immunodeficiency virus.
And the disease that it causes is the acquired immunodeficiency syndrome or AIDS first emerged
in the early 1980s. And again, HIV one may have originated from the chimpanzee virus in Africa.
So one of the possible ideas was that it spread from the jungles in Africa and made it to the
capital cities when men were actually going through the jungles and coming in close contact
with chimpanzees and butchering them and getting the blood and mixing mixing with humans. Now they
think the first documented case of AIDS was actually in 1959. And that, and that it was a slowly
progressive. And then we finally start to see it is when it got into the population in the United
States, and we started seeing this. Now part of the problem was is that it was affecting the
homosexual or gay man population in the early 80s. And that was a bad thing because a lot of people
at that time in the 1980s, this is the era of Reagan and everything else, they kind of turned
their face away from it thinking, well, that's their problem. It's a gay man's disease too bad,
you know, type of thing and saying that's that's God's way of punishing him. And unfortunately,
if we would have done something more at that time, we may have been able to control the spread of
AIDS and or HIV in the population much quicker if people would have actually put some funding and
research. Once it did get into the heterosexual population, that's when people started taking
notice and a lot of people dying from it. And so it took famous people to get it and die from it.
That's when people started to notice and saying, Hey, maybe we need to do something about that.
Unfortunately, that was about five years where things were not done in those situations and
people were dying from the disease. And so a good movie to watch is and the band played on if you
ever want to learn about the early history of AIDS and HIV and the transmission and that stuff
and what was and what wasn't done at that time. I think that's a really good movie. It's an HBO
movie. And so I highly recommend watching that. If you have a chance to do that, you kind of get
a little bit more of the history behind what was going on during that time. And so again,
the spread into the heterosexual population, obviously the fears of blood transmission using
blood from different people and that that was a scary thing. Again, unprotected sex, a lot of
other things spread through contact. And that's how HIV is spread. Okay. And so again, looking at
these different things, we'll talk a little bit about the epidemiology and what it does here in
just a minute, but that just kind of gives you an idea of some of the reasons why perceptions
changed over time because of what was happening. Now the HIV virus is a retrovirus in the genus
lentivirus and it encodes the protein reverse transcriptase, which is an enzyme that makes
double-stranded DNA from RNA. And so it's an important protein that these viruses carry with
them that allows them to convert their RNA into double-stranded DNA in the cell once it infects.
The viral genes permanently integrate into the host DNA and then they can turn on and turn off
the virus when need be. And again, where to tax are your immune cells. It wouldn't be such a big
deal if it had just affected certain cells of the body, but the cells that they infect are a primary
cell in the immune system. And without that cell, you lose the ability to respond to certain infections.
And so it's not so much the HIV kills you by wiping out those cells. It eliminates those cells so
that other infections can come in and now cause severe harm to you. So you now die of opportunistic
infections of all different types due to this infection. And so again, there are two different
types, HIV-1 and HIV-2. HIV-1 is the more common type. The T cell lymphotrophic viruses 1 and 2
and can cause leukemia and lymphoma. And HIV can only infect host cells that have the required CD4
marker plus a core receptor. So again, it's these glycoproteins, the glycoprotein 120 and the glycoprotein
41, which bind to these receptors now on the white cells. It's the CD4 and then the co-receptors
on the white blood cells as well. And you need both of those in order for those things to work.
And again, what happens to the HIV binds to that, gets in and causes the infection. And we know what
cells had the CD4. The immune primary ones are the T helper cells. And if you remember back to chapter
15, the T helper cells are the main cells to activate not only the B cells, but also all the
cytotoxic T cells. So if you eliminate those T cells, those helper cells, you really are in
a world of hurt because the B cells can still activate through antibody in that, but not as
well as they normally can. And there's no chance for the T cell, CD4 cytotoxic cells really to
activate very well without the T helper cells. So if you eliminate those T helper cells, you're
really diminishing the role of the immune system of what it can do. And so that's why people then
start developing these secondary infections and dying from those secondary infections.
Okay. So here's a nice little video to show you how this virus actually works and replicates
inside cells and kind of give you an idea of what's going on. Okay. So let's take a look.
AIDS is caused by the human immunodeficiency virus, HIV. This is an enveloped virus.
The envelope is derived from the host cell membrane with viral glycoproteins such as
GP120 and GP41 inserted into the membrane as the virus leaves the cell. The core is composed
of P24 capsid protein and the P17 matrix protein helps maintain viral structure.
Inside the core are two identical copies of single-stranded RNA viral genome and three enzymes,
reverse transcriptase, RT, protease, PR, and integrase, IN. To establish infection, HIV must first
attach to its host cell. Attachment occurs by interaction between GP120 on the surface of the
virus and the CD4 antigen receptor on the surface of the host cell. In addition to the CD4 receptor,
there must also be a co-receptor on the host cell. The co-receptor differs for different host cell
types. In T lymphocytes, the co-receptor is called CXCR4, whereas on macrophages, the co-receptor is
called CCR5. After attachment, the viral envelope and host cell membrane fuse resulting in entry
of the virus into the cell. Once the RNA is released into the cytoplasm of the host cell,
reverse transcriptase makes a DNA copy of the viral RNA genome. As the DNA is being formed,
reverse transcriptase degrades the RNA strand. A complementary DNA strand is then added by the
reverse transcriptase and the ends of the resulting double-stranded DNA segment are joined non-covalently.
Treatment with nucleoside analogs or reverse transcriptase inhibitors interferes with these
steps. The resulting circular DNA is then moved to the nucleus and inserted into the host cell
chromosome by the viral integrase IN enzyme. The integrated viral DNA is now referred to as
pro-viral DNA. Following integration, the pro-viral DNA may remain dormant or with host cell activation,
RNA may be synthesized from the DNA, yielding messenger RNA and viral genome RNA.
Viral messenger RNA is translated, yielding viral enzymes and structural proteins.
Some of the functional proteins are formed by cleavage of a long polyprotein by the enzyme protease.
Protease inhibitors interfere with this step. GP41 and GP120 are inserted into the host cell
membrane and the structural proteins surround the viral RNA to form the core. Finally, the
virion is released by budding. Okay, so this shows you a nice way of replication. And again,
it takes you through a lot of steps and that stuff. But again, the key that I wanted to show you here
was that again, the DNA gets integrated into the into the host genome. And so that sometimes allows
for HIV to hide for a little while. And so a lot of times what will happen is people will have
a response to HIV very early on when they initially get infected. And then that response goes away
and then you have this kind of lull for anywhere from two to 10 years, maybe even longer depending
on how long that stays integrated. And then you see the HIV come out again, it starts replicating
and it starts attacking and then lowering the cell counts. And so that's what can happen during
these different stages of HIV replication and integration into the DNA. Okay, so again,
the epidemiology of HIV infections transmission occurs through direct and specific routes,
mainly through sexual intercourse and transfer of blood blood products. And babies can be infected
before birth or through breastfeeding. So again, bodily fluids can transmit the disease. And again,
this shows you the virus getting in through the cells, getting into the cells and then spreading
into the different types of cell types. HIV does not survive long outside the body. It's only about
30, 20 to 30 minutes outside on surfaces. So if you do have a blood spill on a surface,
that virus will die within 20 to 30 minutes, but always use universal precautions when dealing
with blood and blood products. Other things might be in there like HPV. Okay, now the epidemiology
of the HIV infection again at first was nationally notifiable in 1984. However, the first cases were
in the late 1970s. It's a six month common cause of death among the age of 25 to 44 years in the
United States and men account for 75% of the new infections. And this can be through IV drug
abusers that can be HIV carriers. And again, a significant factor is spread in the heterosexual
population as well. Not only that, but also transplants and other things before they new and
screaming the blood and everything else. In 2009, the number and infected and visuals worldwide was
estimated to be 35 million people with about 1.2 million in the United States. And again,
the United States doesn't have the most cases, but you're thinking, you know, a million people
have the disease and a million point two people have the disease and will have it the rest of their
lives. Okay, and this just shows you again age groups of which ones have the disease. And again,
the largest is the ages anywhere between 35 and 49, and then 20 to 30, 20 to 34, the two largest
ages. Again, then you can look at what percentage of people, again, ethnicity, black has 54%, where
Hispanics 19, white is 26. Again, the number of men versus women. And then how is it spread? You can
look at heterosexual. It's 33%. IDI, inner drug use, and that is 25%. And men, male to male,
sexual contact is 42%. And so those are how these things spread. And again, different populations
and that stuff, but this still is a problem. I think what has happened is that in the late 80s
and early 90s, there was that fear of HIV, and then that kind of went away. And then people started
not practicing safe steps again. And now we're seeing this increase in HIV again and that stuff,
because you hear about the treatments and other things and that people tend to live longer now
with HIV. But it's still something that you get and you have the rest of your life in will probably
be a significant factor and plays a role in your life span. And so that's one of those things
that's very scary. So you have to be very, very careful again, not along with the STDs and everything
else. But HIV, this is something that's going to stay with you the rest of your life and can
affect a lot of different things in your life as you go along. Now, the primary effects of HIV
infection include extreme leukopenia. So again, your white blood cells go down,
you get the formation of these giant T cells and other syncytia that allow the virus to spread
directly from cell to cell. You get infected macrophages that release the virus into the
central nervous system can have a toxic effect on the brain and spinal cord and can lead to
inflammation. And then the secondary effects of HIV is the destruction of those CD4 lymphocytes,
the T helper cells, and leading you to get the opportunistic infections and malignancies. So
HIV itself is not that deadly, but eliminates the cells that you need for your immune system.
The problem is that you eliminate those cells. Now you're set up going to get all these opportunistic
infections that I've been talking about that only if your immune system is weak and only if
this happens, only if this happens. Now you're subjected to all those different things out there
that normally healthy person wouldn't be affected by. And that's a scary thing. You almost become
one of those people that have to live in a bubble because everything out there has the potential
to infect you. Okay, and that's the scary thing with HIV. Now, diagnosis of AIDS. So HIV and AIDS
are two different things. HIV is the virus. AIDS is the syndrome that occurs once you've reached
the stage of the HIV infection. Again, to be considered to have AIDS, you have to be positive
for the virus. So HIV positive, and then fulfill one of the criteria. The most common criteria
that's fulfilled is the CD4 count of fewer than 200 cells per mil of blood, or their CD4 cells
account for fewer than 14% of all their lymphocytes, and that they experience one or more of the CDC
provided list of AIDS-defining diseases. And again, we're going to talk about all the different
diseases here in just a minute. But any of these criteria along with being HIV positive will then
put you in that category of someone that has acquired immune deficiency disease, or AIDS.
Okay, and so that's what we're going to look at next. Here's a list of the diseases. So again,
can affect all the different systems out there. And again, you basically weaken the immune system
enough now that you are more likely and subjected to a lot of opportunistic infections. And that's
where this comes from. So things like skin and mucous membranes, nervous system, cardiovascular
and lymphatic system, respiratory tract, gastrointestinal tract, and the genital urinary tract are all
likely to get some type of infection. And again, it's just the bombardment of these opportunistic
infections and the inability to fight those off that really causes the person that has AIDS to succumb
to death in these cases. And so that's, that's the serious consequences that eventually all these
people at HIV positive will eventually get to this level depending on how well their treatments work
and how long these treatments work. And then you may suffer from one or more of these diseases.
Okay. So again, preventing and treating HIV, there's no vaccine available. This disease has been around
for at least 30 years. And again, we haven't gotten any closer to coming to a vaccine. Again,
the idea is using universal precautions when you're handling blood products, when auguminous
sexual relationships, wearing condoms, practicing safe sex, all those things. There is no cure for
the disease. Once you have it, so if you're HIV positive, but it shouldn't mean that you are going
to have a death sentence that you're going to die next next week or anything like that. There are a
number of effective ways to slow down the progress of the disease and diminish the symptoms. And it
includes a combination of these things. So a lot of times what they'll give is these protease
inhibitors, reverse transcriptase inhibitors, integrase inhibitors, inhibit diffusion of the
virus getting to cells, the antroviral therapy, we talked about the AZT, which prevents transcription
of the virus. So a combination of these things have actually worked very well in keeping people alive,
much longer than without any treatment whatsoever. And so I don't want you if you are HIV positive,
or you acquire this sometime in the future, that it doesn't mean that you're going to die
tomorrow. There are a lot of helpful treatments out there now. There is no cure yet. But hopefully
down the line that they make enough progress that there's a cure and a vaccine, so we don't
have to worry about it. But this is still a disease that's out there. And it still infects a lot of
people. Just think of this, a million people in the United States alone are infected with about 35
million worldwide. So always be aware of that type of infection, and it's not going away.
Okay, so these people are going to have it the rest of their lives. So that's the thing you need to
think about. Okay, so which of the following cells target the HIV infection? Is it the digidridic cells,
the monocytes, the helper T cells, or all these can support infections? So probably most of you
guys are going to jump out in there and say, see, it's helper T cells, because that's what I'm talking
about. And that would be correct. But it's actually all of these that can support the HIV. It can
get into dendritic cells into monocytes because they do carry the CD4 receptor along with the T
helper cells. Now, by far the T helper cells are the ones that get most effective and actually get
destroyed. But the dendritic and monocytes can harbor the infection for a long period of time
and actually spread the disease to the other parts of the body. So all these cells actually
can support. So if you said d, you got it, right? You're paying some close attention to the lecture
and the notes. All right, so let's finish up with some non-enveloped single-stranded viruses. We got
a couple more left and we'll talk a little bit about these viruses and then move on to the prions
at the very end. But again, in these non-enveloped single-stranded viruses include things like polio,
hepatitis A, and the good old rhinovirus, which is the good old common cold. So we'll talk a little
bit about that as well and why there is no vaccine for the good old common cold. So again, the first
one is the polio virus causes polio malitis. And again, this is an acute intra-viral infection that
infects the spinal cord and causes neuromuscular paralysis. The polio virus is a naked capsid
resistant to acid, bile, and detergents and can survive stomach acids when ingested.
Again, worldwide vaccinations programs have reduced the number of occasions and eventually
eradication will occur. Here's an old box of the polio malitis vaccine, the salt vaccine,
and that again, this was introduced in the 1950s. And again, the virus is spread through
fecal oral routes with contaminated water with fecal material spreads the virus to other people.
And so it enters in through the intestine and then spreads out to the nerves when you get this
infection. So again, it's transmitted fecal oral. The polio virus adheres to the mucosal cells in
the oral pharynx and intestine, multiply and shed in the throat and feces, some leak into blood.
And again, most infections are short-term and mild virinium getting into the blood.
However, these can escape and get into the spinal cord and into the brain. And if that happens,
that's when you start to see the more significant effects of polio in this case. Some develop mild,
non-specific symptoms, including fever, headache, nausea, sore throat, and malayasia. And again,
if erymia persists, the virus spreads the spinal cord in brain. And if the nervous tissue is infected
but not destroyed, it can cause muscle pain and spasm. It can also lead to meningial inflammation
and vague hypersensitivity in those situations. Now, once it gets into the motor neurons, it can
cause flaccid paralysis. So what it does is it blocks again the signaling from the motor neurons
to the muscles. And so you develop this post-polio syndrome, which is a progressive muscle deterioration
and occurs in about 25 to 50% of the patients that are infected with the polio virus in childhood.
So it's a virus that stays around for the for your life. If again, you don't get treated.
Again, about 80 to 85% are asymptomatic. Some get aseptic meningitis. If you get some minor
CNS illnesses and then the paralytic is a very small amount. But again, this is one of those
progressive diseases that we've blocked by vaccination. Now, probably the most common or most what most
of you guys are familiar with is the person or the most famous person that actually had polio as a child
was is the or not Theodore Roosevelt. Franklin Delano Roosevelt, in this case FDR, and he actually
had the disease and he had the crippling disease where basically had muscle weakness in his legs
and started getting to his arms and that stuff. And so during the time with the United States,
they didn't want to show a weekend president during the war. And so they always showed him
covered sitting in a chair, but he was actually, you know, and then he would have braces and other
things to make him stand, allow him to stand up and that stuff. But you never see any pictures of
him in a wheelchair or anything else because they always wanted to proceed make the perception of,
you know, he was a strong president and he could lead the country, especially in the time of war
and that stuff. And so that would, that would have changed things. So in the day today and the social
meeting and everything else, that would never happen. But back in the 1930s and 40s when he was
president, you know, he could get away with it because a lot of people didn't know they only saw
the pictures of him in the newspaper. He looked strong. He would make these strong comments on the
radio and you didn't see it. There wasn't even TV back then. So you wouldn't know about these things.
Now again, prevention is through vaccination. And again, it's an activated polio vaccine,
the salt vaccine. And there is a oral polio vaccine called the saving vaccine. Again,
it's no longer recommended in the United States because we pretty much eliminated polio in this
country. However, there's been some situations in the last couple of years where there have been
these polio like viruses that people have been coming in contact. So we might see a reintroduction
of these vaccines in the next, next couple of years in case in case these numbers continue to
grow and that stuff. And so it'll be interesting to see what happens here in the future. But for now,
most people do not get vaccinated for polio anymore. Okay, worldwide eradication is being
attempted to try and eliminate it from the world, just like smallpox. And again,
the biggest thing is when someone does have this disease is that again, it's progressive
over life and may require ventilation and physical therapy to help strengthen the muscles. But again,
over time, you get paralysis and weakness and eventually death with this disease. Okay, another
one is hepatitis A. And this is an infectious hepatitis that's spread through food. And again,
this is a pecoronavirus that's relatively resistant to heat and acid. It's not carried chronically.
Principal rest of wars are asymptomatic short term carriers and people with clinical disease.
Again, it's passed through the fecal oral route and multiplies in the small intestine and enters
into the blood and is carried to the liver. Now in this case, typically what happens is that people
eat food that's been contaminated with fecal material. A lot of times this comes in your fruits
and vegetables that come from other countries. And it may have been spread. That's why you should
always wash your fruits and vegetables when you get home and that. And then again, the virus can
get in, get into the digestive system. And again, most people cover completely without any problems.
The most common cause is nausea and vomiting that you get. And again, spread through direct
contact with beverages and cups and other things. Again, it does can cause some flu like symptoms
for your cure. John does is very seldom doesn't do a lot of damage to the liver and it's easily
to get over. And so once you do have it, you do develop immunity to it and you won't get it again.
There is a vaccine for it for people. So if they do know of an outbreak, especially in fruits and
that stuff, sometimes you might hear a cafeteria food that was contaminated with it that they may
vaccinate all the kids in that in that school to prevent them from getting the hepatitis A.
Again, there's no specific treatment once the symptoms begin. There isn't an activated viral
vaccine and an attenuated viral vaccine that's given when there's outbreaks reported. And again,
for those that are entering into endemic areas where the words found a lot, you can take a temporary
vaccine to protect yourself from getting in. And again, that's through the immune surveillance,
immune serum globulin. So that would be a passive vaccination again to protect you
if you're going to areas where this virus is seen. Okay, so polio myelitis is generally
acquired through what sexual contact, insect factor, ingestion, or inhalation. How do you get polio?
Remember, it's the fecal oral route. So it would be ingestion. Good job if you got it right. Okay,
so the next one is the human rhinovirus or HRB. And again, there's more than 110
serotypes associated with the common cold. This is a unique molecular surface that makes development
of a vaccine unlikely. And so since there are so many different particles that are out there
and they can change very easily, and there are so many strains going and circulating at a time that
really a vaccine for the common cold is probably going to be unlikely because there are so many
strains out there, so many types, serotypes that in the unique structure of it that making a vaccine
towards the common cold will probably be unlikely. And that's unfortunate because we all suffer from
it. Again, many strains circulate in the population at one time and are acquired from contaminated
hands and surfaces. So these viruses stay around for you to touch, touch your mouth and bring it in,
and that's how you get it or again, respiratory droplets breathing those in, but typically from
the contaminated surfaces. Now, again, the human rhinovirus is sensitive to acid environments.
The optimum temperature is 33 degrees C, so below our temperature. It does cause headache,
chills, fatigue, sore throat, cough, and nasal drainage. Again, treat the symptoms in these
cases and hand washing and care and handling nasal secretions are always a big thing.
Here I have a list just comparing the cold or flu. Do you have a cold or do you have the flu?
And typically the biggest difference is fever. Fever is associated with the flu where you get
an usually high fever, where with the cold it's pretty rare that you ever get a fever. You might
get a low grade fever about maybe 100 degrees, but most of the time you don't get a fever associated
with flu. It's very likely you're going to have a fever at least 100, 103, maybe even 104.
The general aches and pains throughout your body with a cold is primarily limited to the upper
respiratory system and that so you may have a headache in that, but with the flu it's all over.
You know the difference between that. And again, a lot of times you see that with the cold,
definitely a stuffy nose, sneezing, sore throat, and again with flu that only occurs sometimes.
Chest discomfort, again the cough, and again lots of different treatments over the counters
and that stuff. Proventions are pretty much the same except the banal vaccination with the flu.
And again complications may include sinus congestion, malaria, infection, where these can be life
threatening. And so again a cold is much much less likely to cause severe disease. Again it's more
of an inconvenience or a nuisance that we suffer, get over it, and move on and that stuff and it
spreads very easily. Whereas the flu, this is something different, this is going to be much more
overall body, just basically wipes you out and you're out for a couple of days, you know,
where you know that you're really really sick and there is a potential for life threatening
complications with the cold, not so much. And again it's primarily going to stick to the
the head and neck region with that sore throat, coughing, sneezing, and that and then more of a
nuisance like I said, you get over it and time goes on. Okay. Now the last group of viruses
that we're going to talk about are the double stranded RNA viruses and associated with this
are the diarrhea, vomiting, and fever. And so these are a lot of times what we see with infantile
diarrhea and those that spread from many people at one time. And so you hear about these things
like on cruise ships and other places where these spread pretty quickly. Okay so the two are the
rheovirus and the rhodovirus and again it's a cold like upper respiratory infection and can cause
enterteditis. So this is a lot of times what people think is a 24 hour flu or something similar to that.
The rhodovirus is an oral fecal transmission, the primary viral cause of morbidity and mortality
and children resulting in diarrhea and infants and children. Again this is severe case associated
with this is dehydration, severe diarrhea, cramping, vomiting, and other things like that. And again
typically where healthcare is pretty poor and clean water is really difficult that's where you're
going to see most of the deaths. Most of the time most people recover pretty easily to get
rehydration, electrolytes, and you know the typical stimulants to help you get over the diarrhea in
the situation. Okay. The last group that we're going to talk about today is the infectious
protein particles and again these are the prions. And so I just wanted to show you some of the
differences between prions and the different types of diseases out there. And again typically
what occurs is that it gets into the neural tissue. These proteins start to grow in the nervous system,
nervous tissue, and starts eating away at the brain. And so that's what happens. You start to see
these holes in the brain. So that's what you're seeing. You get shrinkage in the brain and
de deterioration that it causes. And again the differences is in this protein. Here's the normal
prion protein. It's called PRP that we have in our brain. What happens is that it gets mutated
by this abnormal protein and our normal proteins start to look like this. The problem with this
is that it doesn't degrade. And so it just builds up, builds up, builds up. And what you can see
is it starts putting holes in the brain. And that's the scary thing. Okay. Now the prions in the
spongiform encephalopathies, the prions are protonaceous infectious particles highly resistant to
chemicals, radiation. And again here's the normal protein. Here's the abnormal protein. And what it
causes is this transmittable spongiform encephalopathies in both humans and animals. And it's a neurodegenerative
disease with long incubation periods. Here's short term. Here's long term. You can see these
areas where the tissue is just being degraded. You see these large areas where it's just cleared
out. And basically what's there is filled of protein. And so that protein just continues to
build, build, build. There's no degradation. This protein has to go somewhere. And so it starts
destroying cells around it because it has to fill the space with this protein. Okay. Now again,
some of the characteristics is very resistant to chemicals and radiation and heat. It does not
present virus morphology and electron, more microscopy of infected brain tissue. It's integrated into
nucleic acid and infected host cell are not integrated. I'm sorry, unlike the viruses. It's
protein in nature. No DNA or RNA. Does not elicit inflammatory reaction or reaction or psychopathic
effects in the host. Does not elicit antibody formation in the host. And it's responsible for
vacuoles and abnormal fibers forming in the brain of the host. And it's transmitted only by close
direct contact with infected tissues and secretions. So again, you have to come in contact with these
things and physically almost eat the stuff to get it inside you so that you get these infections.
Now, the one that causes the human encephalopathy is called crusphylgecope disease or CJD. It's an
alteration in the structure of the normal PRP protein and it's found in the brain. So we have
the normal PRP and then it gets mutated into the abnormal. Now there is a slight, slight
possibility probably less than 0.1 percent. The chance that a normal protein could mutate into
this abnormal one and it builds this way. More likely where people get this as they get it from
an infected source that has this abnormal protein, either another person or another animal that
has this and then they get it into their nervous system. The abnormal PRP results in nerve cell
deaths, spongiform damage, and severe loss of brain function. Again, transmission is through
direct or indirect contact with an infected brain tissue or cerebral spinal fluid. Now,
what's interesting is that one of my former students just sent me an article saying about
I think it was the hospital down in Raleigh, North Carolina is dealing with this issue
primarily where basically they had to shut down all the surgeries that were going on because
their instruments were contaminated with this CJD. And again, it was because they were working on
someone that they didn't know at the time had it, but it turns out she had it. Now everything is
contaminated with this and so now they have to go in and sterilize. So before they can perform
any other surgeries, they have to sterilize everything and the sterilization techniques are
a lot different than the normal sterilization that we use in our equipment. And so you have to do
special things in order to clean things up. And so this can shut down a hospital for many days to
many weeks, depending on how severe this outbreak was or how many instruments or whatever she was
in came in contact with and that they have to change now because of it. And so this can be a
severe situation in that. And again, this is found not only in humans, but also in other mammals,
including cows, which is the mad cow disease found in sheep, which is called scrappy, and then in
the deer and elk population called chronic wasting disease. And again, they test for this when people
go hunting, the DNR will test the animals. So when you bring the animal to the DNR after you
to tag in everything, they will test. And if it comes out positive, you are not allowed to
handle that animal anymore, they will confiscate it and take our way from you. So that's the
unfortunate thing. And so, but it's for your safety as well as the safety of others so that you don't
get the disease. You don't want this disease. There's no cure. There's no way to get rid of this
protein once it's inside of you. And that's the scary thing. Okay. With the human encephalopathy,
the variant CJD became apparent in the late 1990s after eating meat from cattle,
affected with the bovine smungiform encephalopathy. It's difficult to diagnose and
records examination of the biopsy brain or nervous tissue. And again, you can see the
difference. Here's a normal brain. Here's one with CJD. And again, you see the shrinking of the brain
in areas or pockets where the brain is being, the spongy form brain is being eaten away.
Prevention relies on avoidance of contaminated tissues. And again, treatments focuses on easing
the symptoms. There is no cure. Once you get this, this is your, this is going to be your life.
And again, it's a slow progressive death where again, you start to lose motor function. You slip
into a coma and you eventually die from this disease. There's not much you can do once you get this
protein in your brain, unfortunately. Okay. And so, this is a nice little video to show you how
the prions arise. I like showing this just to give you an idea of where this protein comes from
and how, how it spreads throughout the body. So let's take a look at this.
There is evidence that the infectious agent associated with certain brain diseases,
such as Creutzfeld-Yachob disease in humans and mad cow disease in animals, may be caused by a
protein. The infectious agent has been called a prion for protonaceous infectious particle.
The normal prion protein, PRPC, is bound to the surfaces of neurons and the gene for PRP
is present in normal vertebrates and invertebrates. Presumably, the normal prion protein, PRPC,
can be altered and the altered prion protein, PRPSC, SC meaning "scrapey associated",
becomes misfolded and takes on a different conformation. Many researchers believe that the
infective agent is this alternative protein conformation. It is believed that when PRPSC
enters a normal brain, it binds to the normal cellular PRP, PRPC, and induces it to fold into
the abnormal conformation. The newly produced PRPSC molecule may then convert more normal PRPC
proteins into the abnormal PRPSC form. An alternative hypothesis is that PRPSC
could activate enzymes that modify the PRPC structure, not shown.
So I like this video because it shows you exactly what happens during the progression of the disease.
So not only do you get infected with this protein, but the protein can then go and change the normal
protein you have into this scrappy protein or this SC protein. And so that's the scary thing,
is that it's a progressive disease. Not only do you get this protein and it keeps replicating
on its own, but it changes your normal protein into the prion protein that you don't want.
Okay, and that kind of shows you how this disease progresses.
All right, so we made it to the end. This is the last video. You made it. Congratulations.
Let's finish up with the summary, and we'll call it good for today. To summarize, we saw
numerous types of RNA viruses. And again, they're based on not only the type of RNA that they have
in the inside, but if they're enveloped or non-enveloped in that. And again, we talked a lot about
some different ones. The envelope segment in RNA includes influenza. The HNN proteins are the
important thing, you know, or the not proteins, but the glycoproteins, yeah, glycoproteins on
there that are important. I talked about antigenic shift versus drift, and that, and knowing the
difference between those, we talked about the envelope, non-segment, RNA, measles, mumps,
rabies, hepatitis C, a lot of those viruses, again, are protection through vaccination,
but again, can cause some disease in those that haven't been vaccinated. The arbroviruses are the
arthropod-borne, and that includes the West Nile, yellow fever, Zika virus that also be included in
here. The retroviruses are the HIV. We did a lot about HIV. I like to ask a lot of questions about
HIV on the test. And again, it's not so much the lot of the general things that we saw. And again,
what cells do they infect? Why? What happens during the process? What causes death in a lot of these
people in that? And so, you know, just knowing the basics, I think you're going to be fine,
looking at that, that don't spend too much time in that. We talked briefly about the non-enveloped
RNA viruses, including polio, hepatitis A, and the cold viruses, the rhinoviruses. And then finally,
we finished up with the double-stranded RNA. And that was the Rio and the rhodoviruses. And again,
these cause the infantile diarrhea. Again, proper hydration and electrolyte therapy is what you do
in these situations. However, in areas where you don't see that, that's where it can lead to death.
And then finally, we finished up with the infectious protein particles. We looked at prions,
which are the indestructible protein particles. It's completely proteinaceous. There's no DNA
involved or RNA in these situations. It gets passed by protein. And again, you have to come in contact
with those proteins in order to get infected. And so, we talked about the human form, which is the
CJD or Kreitzfeld, Jacob disease. And again, that is the human spongiform encephalopathy. And again,
it gets into the brain, changes those normal PRP proteins to the abnormal ones. They don't get
broken down. They build up in the brain and then lead to destructive features into the brain and
leading to death and those that are infected. Okay? So, we made it to the end. If you have any
questions, please feel free to email me, send me comments and do all those wonderful things.
Stop me in my office, ask me in the lab. I'd be happy to talk to you about these things. I find
it very interesting. Hopefully, this wasn't too overwhelming in that and those things. And, you know,
if there was a way to get this cut down shorter, I would. But I like to talk and give you a little
information about that at the same time and that stuff. And like I said, if you do have any questions,
let me know. Thanks for being in great class, everything else, and watching these videos and
taking the time and watching those. Like I said, if you do have any questions, please ask. You made
it to the end. Last one. And good luck to you in the future and all that you do. Okay? Thanks for
watching. And I won't see you next time.